the Disney Channel just released The
Descendants 3 trailer and fans are going
wild the short teaser gives us plenty to
go on and we're already forming some
theories of our own watch until the end
to find out what the trailer means for
now Open Sesame
The Descendants 3 trailer is filled with
exciting scenes and epic battles so
we're totally expecting the film to keep
us on the edge of our seats the first
thing we see flash across the screen is
a gate it seems to be opening on its own
or with the help of something dark and
powerful if you pause here real quick
you'll notice what appears to be
Sleeping Beauty spinning we'll in the
center of the room were under the
impression that this scene is warning us
of what's to come is our Don Pratt being
broken into is an evil presence
infiltrating the school it sure seems
like it the crown the scene switches so
quickly that it's hard to confirm or
whether or not we're in the same room
but from where we're standing it looks
like the same dark presence that opens
the gate is now opening to steal a crown
the crown is beautiful and encrusted
with hundreds of jewels but why is the
headpiece being featured in the opening
scene of the trailer the way the teaser
zooms into it makes us think that it's
incredibly valuable in fact were led to
believe that it's been stolen and now
and her crew are being sent to retrieve
it motorcycles after the mysterious
crown disappears from our review we see
a group of four motorcyclists driving
towards the water's edge from the looks
of it were staring at Maui BJ and Carlos
and they're suited up and what appears
to be Power Ranger gear they're clearly
on a mission and since this is the third
scene being showcased in the trailer we
predict that the gang won't waste much
time before traveling to the Isle of the
Lost mal and her friends are clearly on
a mission to retrieve something from
their hometown while we're aware that
they're also looking to recruit some
villains to their side there also seems
to be a rescue mission underway the
prisoner the next thing we see is mal
opening a door with a skeleton key and
then an unknown person is rescued from a
jail cell we see as big combat boots
touch the ground a few
seconds later and we can't help but
notice that there are hints of blue in
them could this be the all-powerful
Hades that we've been dying to me or is
this villain who tried to rise up
against Emma only to pay the price
unfortunately we don't get to see the
prisoners face but if it is Hades it's
possible that he's pretending to be
Mao's father to gain her trust if so
many movies are in fact working together
he might be posing as her prisoner to
come off as a good guy now that's sneaky
the battle the trailers contents flash
across the screen so quickly that it's
hard to get a good look at every single
scene come on Disney can't you just give
us a real trailer we've waited long
enough it's easy to see that descendants
3 is going to be loaded with action
scenes in fact the trailer showcases the
gang fighting against armed soldiers
with swords
however the villains don't seem too
fazed by this because well they're all
well versed in swordplay this battle
takes place in the same room that is
showcased in the opening scene of the
trailer but this time the gates are
closed preventing the villains from
leaving without a fight but then again
we didn't really expect them to run The
Spectre the next few scenes are a little
confusing but after becoming best
friends with the pause button we're
pretty sure that we caught some crucial
details first of all we come face to
face with a doctor facile ears layer but
the image switches in a flash the
trailer then jumps to Jay's puzzled face
and quickly changes to show a woman
walking through the woods with the green
staff in her hand upon further
inspection we've discovered that this
staff is actually Maleficent Spectre but
this revelation causes more questions
than it does answers fans pointed out
that Audrey was last seen holding the
magical Specter so couldn't be that
Audrey and dr. Vasily are working
together if so we believe that her
biggest desire is to be like now after
all she does have everything Audrey ever
wanted the Beast if you manage to keep
your eyes peeled throughout the entire
trailer you probably noticed a little
beast clutching to a tree well if this
isn't a Ben we don't know what it is
poor Ben has always been afraid that
he'd be
be steeped like his father but he was
pretty lucky in the looks department but
now it looks like Ben is having a super
hard time dealing with his new
appearance during this scene we see
Harry and Gil in the background which
leads us to believe that they've joined
the good side but these villains be
working together towards a common goal
or are Harry and Gil responsible for
turning Ben into a beast
our money's on Audrey who appears to
have Maleficent Spectre sorry Ben you
should have stayed with Audrey when you
had the chance
who is crystal isn't Loomis simply the
best sure she's evil and all but last
time we checked we all loved getting a
little wicked this team begins and ends
in the nick of time
so causing it at the right moment is
like uncovering buried treasure at this
point we see uma gazing into a blue
crystal with a mesmerized look on her
face the diamond is the same shade of
blue as Katie's hair and aura so some
fans believe this jewel to be Emma's way
of communicating with the god of the
underworld
in fact we're pretty sure that this is
the crystal showcased on the escape from
the Isle of the Lost book cover what do
you guys think this crystal is being
used for a power enhancer a communicator
or something else entirely Hades Hades
is predicted to be the big bad so we can
only expect him to wreak havoc on our
don prep but what we didn't expect
however was to see uma fighting
alongside mal and the other V Ches
during the scene we see mal and the gang
sword fighting with huge metal Knights
disappears to be the battle we are shown
at the beginning of the trailer but now
we clearly see that the Pirates are
joining in on the action the scene
starts cutting out as the music
intensifies and it's here that we get
our first glimpse of Hades and guys it's
safe to say that he's up to no good if
this really is Mouse dad he doesn't seem
to care about his daughter's well-being
whatsoever green eyed mal the last thing
we see is a breathless mal turning
around to face the camera her eyes glow
a bright green before the trailer cuts
out The Descendants logo then quickly
flashes across the screen and at this
point we see one of dr. Vasily Aires
card
floating to the surface oddly enough mal
as the persons shown in the cover of the
card so could it be that Audrey was so
jealous of mouth that she struck a deal
with dr. facile ear if so this could
explain why she was able to hold
Maleficent sceptre without falling into
a deep deep sleep so if the mau we see
in the last scene is actually Audrey
this could explain why her eyes suddenly
turned green
it looks like mal is in big trouble let
us know if you noticed anything we
didn't in the comments below we post new
videos every single day so make sure to
subscribe to the things to be the first
in line for the latest news thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]